Tên bàu trung của mình sẽ ẳng, hạt lòng thân 2,
đang luật thông biệt mừng tình phát xí trên,
đã đến tạm mặt hội phục biến như ấy.
Ê, Instagram, Facebook, Instagram và YouTube,
gêu gọi người y ra lịch là Anquang và cùng các thông tiền cho các bạn này.
Trong thông biệt, sẽ ẳng, đề nghịnh người y ra an không xử dụng để thật ra,
cho anh em may tình gêu gọi an.
Âu tiền xử dụng thiết bị mời dụng một lần,
tránh đề người khác nhìn thấy mang hình bà xử dụng phần mề VPN,
không đập may trụ, đánh gà,
và nhìn mạnh ươi điện dạc quyết phần nè phán,
kẻ báo, sẽ không đề tây hệ ra an sở vì vui ở nhà nhận.
Phó tổng thông tiền đi bàn sña hẹp lòng sống hãi cho biệt.
Vậy là người ta có bằng chứ như cho thấy tây ra,
có đằng xa ra xây dụng trình thử dụng.
Hãi nhớ đi, xa có cuộc tần, con mì ý hội thằng xo năm ngoài,
về ở nhà tất cả các bạn, để chơi chình hãi nhìn của mình,
chỉ phục buộc một lịch, hoa bình.